dans le sud-ouest de l'île?
Jean-Sébastien Cloutier est allé
sonder le terrain.
♪ ♪ ♪
- Voici la rue la plus cool
de la planète, selon le magazine
international "Time Out".
Avec ses restaurants, ses barse,
la rue Wellington symbolise
le nouveau Verdun : branché
et gentrifié, plus jeune
et multiculturel. 60 % des
électeurs sont francophones.
Le paysage politique
changera-t-il lui aussi?
FRANÇOIS LEGAULT,
chef, Coalition avenir Québec
- Je ne veux pas rien prendre
pour acquis, mais ça sent bon
à Verdun.
- François Legault a visité
la circonscription la semaine
dernière. La CAQ met toute
la gomme pour faire élire
Véronique Tremblay.
- On a des bénévoles qui
s'ajoutent tous les jours,
il y en a encore qui vont
s'ajouter.
- Actuellement conseillère
municipale dans l'équipe
de Valérie Plante, elle promet
des logements abordables
et une nouvelle école.
VÉRONIQUE TREMBLAY,
candidate, CAQ, Verdun
- Je pense vraiment que je peux
jouer un rôle intéressant.
Je trouve que c'est important
que Montréal soit plus
représentée.
- Elle avait flirté
libéraux en 2016
pour être leur candidate.
- Puis finalement, ils ont
choisi quelqu'un d'autre,
puis je comprenais très bien
le choix. J'aime les défis,
puis j'aime quand les choses
avancent. Et c'est pour ça
que j'ai joint la CAQ :
parce que je les trouvetrès pro.
- Dans l'Île-des-Soeurs,
où elle habite, un secteur
surtout francophone et plus
riche de la circonscription,
certains électeurs
la critiquent.
- Ça m'énerve! Facilement
comme ça, de sauter d'un parti
à l'autre...
- Mais beaucoup appuient la CAQ
et son chef.
- Avant, oui, j'étais libérale.
Moi, M. Legault, je l'aime bien.
Donc, j'ai trouvé qu'il avai
fait une bonne job. Donc,
pour l'instant, je pense
que ça va être mon choix.
- Les francophones, on est tous
pour la CAQ, t'sais, parce que
Legault nous ressemble.
Ce n'est pas un grand
intellectuel qui parle
en grandes phrases, là.
- Moi, c'est Alejandra.
- Je vous connais, vous avez
mon vote déjà.
- Ah, merci!
- Mais Québec solidaire se voit
aussi gagner Verdun, qui,
par endroits, rappelle de plus
en plus le Plateau-Mont-Roya
Sa candidate est Alejandra Zaga
Mendez, la présidente du parti.
ALEJANDRA ZAGA MENDEZ,
candidate, QS, Verdun
- Verdunès, très
diversifié. Moi, je suis
vraiment fière de cette
diversité-là. Moi-même,
je viens d'un milieu immigrant,
sens qu'onsens qu'onsens qu'onst
connecter avec tout le monde,
même les personnes anglophones.
Is Québec solidaire
one of your options?
- Yes.
- Good!
(rires)
- Avec son doctorat en économie
écologique, elle est derrière
l'ambitieux plan de lutte contre
les changements climatiques
proposé par le parti.
- Ici, là, on a un accès
au fleuve, à Verdun,
puis on le sait à quel point
c'est important de protéger
nos berges, à quel point c'est
important de lutter contre
les îlots de chaleur.
- Son message rejoint les je
en particulier.
- Il y a un projet de société
mis de l'avant, puis surtout
une réponse aux changements
climatiques. Je pense que
vraiment, la vague orange
est déjà enclenchée ici.
- Avez-vous peur de perdre
votre château fort?- Bien moi, s
à ma troisième élection ici
à Verdun, je n'ai jamais rien
pris pour acquis.
- Isabelle Melançolgré
tout confiante d'être réélue
pour les libéraux.
ISABELLE MELANÇON,
candidate, PLQ, Verdun
- Verdun, c'est un grand
village, les gens sont tissés
serrés, et je pense qu'en ce
sens-là, les gens reconnaissent
que mon travail, c'en est
un de proximité.
- Comme ce midi-là, où elle fait
dans une coopérative
d'habitation pour aînés.
- Moi, ce qui me fait le plus
plaisir, c'est quand les gens
me disent : "Moi, là, je s
une Isabelle." Il n'y a pas
de couleur partisane.
- Son bilan comme députéesembles
que son parti.
- Elle connaît les organismes,
elle connaît les enjeux locaux,
elle est impliquée au niveau
de l'Hôpital de Verdun.
- Notre Isabelle!
On l'aime tellement!Elle nous a.
- Continuons avec Melançon.
C'est bon, ça! On va le garder,
le slogan!
- Isabelle Melançon l'avait
remporté par 3600 voix dans
Verdun en 2018, devant Québec
solidaire et la CA
Ici Jean-Sébastien Cloutier,
Radio-Canada, Mon